WE DID IT!
Yatta desu ne!
First to 90 million.
Oh boOoOy!
T-Series was right behind us but we did it!
👏
We did it
Omedetou
👏
Omedetou gozai
Omedetou gozaimasu!
👏
Very nice!
Thank you, everyone!
👏
I can't believe!
Everything is just changing so quickly.
You have all these...
um... news ariticles pre, er-
Is it called 'Preemptively'?
--Yeah! Preemptively celebrating the fact that T-Series has passed us,
BUT OH NO NO NO!
I think that's important to know,
that UNLESS, we have a common goal,
this is just gonna go on forever.
And I think we've proven ourselves that we're more than capable,
of doing just THAT,
okay?
But if we don't have a common goal,
then we are just gonna look like a bunch of idiots.
We're never gonna- go this is just gonna go on forever.
Which, it easily can, bY thE wAy.
Which is fine!
But, we are more than that.
We have more integrity than that, we're not:
"oH, wE hAvE tO bEaT tHem, bEbE!"
We don't CARE! Okay?!
It's first... to a hundred million,
AND THEN...
we will let T-Series passes us.
we will let L-Series passes us.
You will have my permission to PASS,
AFTER we hit a hundred million,
I will write full a step aside,
I will graciously step aside and let you pass, T-Series!
*LWIAY Intro*
Using the Drake format
Using the new Marzia format because Marzia memes get more upvotes than pewds memes
WHAT?!
I can do funny faces, guys, please! UwU
[Fairy Tall] Wow (echo)
They were thirty thousand ahead!
I don't know how they did it!
I don't understand *???*
just don't forget about me when I lose to T-Series
Well, it's not gonna happen!
It's not losing, if we
let them win!
Okay?!
10 Jeahr challenge Fortnite in 10 months
but Minecraft never
in ten yeahrs
I'm so proved of community
Yeah.
like a meme to uh neurotically play play
minecraft it used to be oh you play
minecraft oh that's awesome - oh you
play minecraft only kids play minecraft
oh you play minecraft that gave us dead
- you play minecraft Thank You Hana
brofist bro hit a freaking fat brofist
self-driving cars more likely to hit
wild deer oh my god please the story
writes itself
Felix we need explanation clown poor
listen we don't know the source we don't
know who posted this and we don't know
why this was made so therefore we will
ignore this news moving a hug at 100
million we're deleting the channel we
don't know the source of this this ah
when we hit 50 million I added a little
Easter egg at the very end saying yeah
I'm deleting the channel at a hundred
million so haters better start
subscribing okay violent videos mods
closing down this sub young children
they big shoutouts to the to the mods I
appreciate that they they acted quickly
to prevent that I think they did a great
job and I really appreciate it Japanese
reinforcements are available pukes one
day I would like to very much
take a collaboration video with pity son
Kizuna ie for me review
if the game is so relevant why haven't
the headphones changed ah oh my god this
is so embarrassing yeah our minds I
thought the game was relevant they told
me listen they told me Felix the game is
so relevant and I'm like this is awesome
I'll tell everyone how relevant the game
is I felt so disappointed
while I made pewds what an amazing guy
next me
Thank You Shane very cool he said
something I appreciate a lot in his
video today almost nights a thing that I
did mention in that video is that I said
that I watched him back in the day but I
like Shane a lot more now because he
seems like he's more honest and open
with himself and I think that's the
thing with YouTube that I really like so
keep going Shane you're doing great it
works i screen recorded and uploaded a
video with a song
Oh hit books so there's this theory that
it's not a theory but this is mean that
to fight if you don't know the name of a
song just upload it to YouTube because
they have all this advanced technology
to claim the video it's so it will say
what song it is because they will get
claim well if you upload it and someone
did it
hi dragon boy yo the Content ID claim ur
is time is on my side
claimed by um G I think I heard
somewhere the reason why you can't sing
happy birthday on
is that the one sing happy birthday and
it will cost you
turns out the pablor song is under
copyright performers are supposed to pay
do not you're not allowed to sing it
happy birthday to you at restaurants
because it's not licensed just to give
you a taste of how bad then in my
opinion the music industry is with with
protecting the artists it is certain no
integrity involved with sharing
something that you created I don't get
this idea but it's literally the same
thing here on YouTube even if I hum a
song that's enough for a video to get
claimed entirely
I can't wait for article 13 I really
hope I'm just imagining things
Oh God break out on forehead bags under
eyes substance abuse I think feelings
needs a vacation to the records he looks
so drink concern nine-year-old I
appreciate the concern it's been a rough
couple days it's time for the big guns
pewds happy wheels fortnight minecraft
roblox cool man
I really got to play happy wheels I
don't know if I can do it man
her he's probably thinking about other
women him I wonder if there is someone
who is subscribed to prettify
submissions but isn't subscribed to
PewDiePie you know here you are hit that
subscribe button when God created
feelings good looks that's right
thanks right a girlfriend that's right I
do have a girlfriend number one most
subscribe YouTube channel
legs oops dog for those of you hasn't
missed who has missed the breaking news
that's right in order to defeat t-series
I have revealed that I have very large
tongue as I will show you now
the war is still odd well clear ah it
hits zero again oh god it zero again one
ahead fast
ah this is why I hate video games it
appeals to male fantasy oh my god
I have Leahey finally a video game where
I can live my fantasy teaser is so but
caught alive holy crap
whoa whoa what what what happened there
they gained 25,000 out of nowhere
Oh 31% off G fuel pay 69% of the price
oh my god guys leak the case you didn't
know you get 16 you can pay 69% of the
full price of G fuel
it's the biggest sale they've ever had
if you enter the code PT pipe
number 5 trending for gaming in India
hey we did it guys
we settled for number 5 now apparently
what the hell is this fan out of the
original nine year olds and yes the guy
in the back is sigh they made sigh look
like a total boy everybody everybody gay
as always
that's a great name
you like your lose meme reviews bad
camera quality Brad one pew news book
reviews 35 and that's how it's done
everybody all men
have a mental age of nine you know
you're not 9 but in there you're 9 we
are all we are all silly oh my god he
gets it
wow that's nothing here just a scream
subscore no sub subs I thought it was
gonna say subscribe subscribe to judy by
pew you laugh you win his entire fanbase
wait that's silly sometimes you just got
to pull some strings to makes things
happen
I made a skin for Peter pine for night
took three hours couldn't find a face
that looks like him but I hope he likes
it damn see I saw these on Twitter but I
didn't know what it was from that's
really cool I'm pretty sure the only
thing to save for night from a famous
legend is to add this skin I won't just
remember March 18 as a day my twin
daughters were born but also the day
pivot I became the first title to
surpass 90 million subscribers
congratulations of your twins man that's
incredible
thank you guys so much for all the
support honestly it means so much to me
if you want support the channel just
it's there and that's it for me for now
see you guys tomorrow
why brofist at a hundred million
brofist that 100 min to burst simulator
it's now so relevant that it's got a
brand new mini game cranium drop the
crane and get fresh items only available
in the washing machine like game and you
say there's more of course there is new
Seriously Subscribe were you even watching the vid
Animu speak to English by Pandora YW